We are all natural born learners.
Full of determination, we take unimaginable risks.
Exploding with curiosity, we
achieve the extraordinary.
But as we grow up our love for
learning is put to the test.
Some are told that they are not good enough.
Or are given up on
While a few strive, many begin to
see their natural curiosity fade away
or begin associating learning with anxiety.
Children can’t do much about that, but adults can.
We can educate ourselves and change the experience
that kids have in our homes and classrooms.
That is why we have built
a school for little people
and share everything we learn along the way.
That's why we make videos that explain complex
social, psychological and pedagogical ideas
to new parents, students and teachers.
And that is why we publish all our
materials via the creative commons license
and allow anyone to freely use them
for all sorts of educational purposes.
Today one million people have
subscribed to our channel,
over 50 million people have watched our videos
and our channel is sprouting
up in several major languages.
Your views, your likes and your meaningful
comments are what keeps us going.
And we want to thank every single
one of you who helped us get here!
On our website, you’ll find
all videos for download,
plus additional resources
and classroom activities.
If you want to support us, join
our community and become a Patron
and help us change education, one mind
at a time! That's patreon.com/sprouts.